welcome back to new rockstars i'm philip
molina and this is fitness origins it's
a fitness competition show that takes
inspiration from the films of the mcu
and uses them to get my fellow nerds
eric voss and tommy bechdel
into thor shape i mean like maybe not
exactly
thor but they do each kind of look like
him in their own way
anyway this week is the kickoff to phase
three
of their fitness origins and we're gonna
kick it into the highest gear with
inspiration
from thor three that's right the time
has come for
ragnarok the ragnarok has already begun
eric tommy how you guys doing phillip
uh great i mean i feel eric i hate to
say this every week i think i'm
good i think my fitness origins are over
you're done uh you don't have to do
anything else then does that mean i win
no he already said you're done i win i'm
taking this to the bank oh sorry papa i
didn't mean to be fresh papa
all right so you so you want to know
what the theme of this week is oh i
already know what the theme is
it's ragnarok it's a horniest mcu movie
so i assume to burn those calories we're
gonna have a thousand year orgy
oh phillip i love that great idea by you
i did not say that
can we order that on doordash it's not a
thousand-year orgy
that's not what we're doing for the week
what we
are doing is what thor ragnarok was
really actually about
one the grand masters not orgy gladiator
battles
uh no i actually don't want the two of
you to actually fight each other because
that would be a disaster i assume you
you guys know how that would turn out
well tommy is a friend from work which
means i will destroy him
yeah i was gonna say it would just turn
into a kissing contest it would start
off as wrestling a lot of tickling more
tickling than punching that's for sure
a lot of hugging and crying probably
therapy it would be like group therapy
do not hug or kiss or fight or anything
uh instead
you're going to compete all week long in
a more specific
gladiator level way because each of your
workouts is now
asking you that you step it up all the
way to the phase
three versions of those challenges if
you successfully
do the phase three version of the
workout which is the hardest version
each time you do that that's gonna be a
blow
you land on your opponent so i gotta
blow my opponent till he dies
it's not a thousand year orgy okay got
it okay sorry
you know up until this point my family's
been like we love these episodes this is
gonna be the week where they turn up
earlier uh all right our second
inspiration
is leather daddies we're dressing up
like ella with
horn antlers that is a stretch you
are not doing leather costumes all right
just tell us
okay fine hella does cause the event and
that
is ragnarok it's the [ __ ] apocalypse
and here's what i want you to know no
matter how hard you work
how nice you are how hard you hug your
little mommies
i really like eric bock the apocalypse
is not
optional it is coming it is going to
happen
your worst nightmares they're gonna come
true
philip have you been talking to that
fisherman who we ran over in college and
we said we would never talk about ever
again but
we both secretly dream about at night uh
no i was talking about your worst
fitness nightmares so eric you seem to
be oh so scared of this idea that you're
never gonna have enough time to dedicate
to exercise
for me it's like you know it's still
finding
the time to fit these in so for this
entire week we're gonna make that
true you don't have time to dedicate to
exercise and you're gonna
[ __ ] love it you're gonna have to get
your workouts in
while you do another task that you can't
skip
like laundry or working on a video or
watching a movie or tickling your little
wiener
or whatever it is you're gonna get your
workout in
on top of that this week how am i
supposed to do that
for a 35 minute session of hit training
you'll have to figure it out
you can do squats while you paint the
wall and you'll naturally go up and down
and you thomas you're so scared of
looking
stupid you're telling me i i went
downstairs today to make a breakfast
protein shake and i accidentally put all
of the ingredients in the microwave and
oh did i feel foolish
it was more of a porridge it was more of
a protein stew my point is
you're scared of what people will think
of you when they see you work out well
too bad
i want you to do every single workout
this week
in front of somebody else can be a
relative it can be a friend oh it could
be some strangers whoever it is
you can't hide from them you have to let
them see
everything oh every so i could do it in
the nude i
did not say that and the authorities
will stand by what i said i did not say
you had to be naked
i'm excited you know what i'm conquering
my fear i am
thor so we're now in phase three
and the challenge of this week i guess
cause the theme is thor ragnarok
i have to embrace my fears and someone
upstairs decided that my fear was
not having enough time to do everything
it's not a fear it's just a weakness
trying to work out and get in all this
stuff while watching
mortal kombat uh i'm really really bad
at multitasking
i should be writing some of this down
i'm just going to like re-watch the
whole first half of it
and i feel like i didn't get a very good
workout in really i think the ragnarok
of this week is
eric just falls way behind on his work
and gets in a bad workout
philip knows my greatest fear is looking
stupid when i work out so he asked me
to work out with other people this week
so i recruited
my roommate garrett hi garrett garrett's
a very
fit handsome man neither here nor there
so yeah you just hold the camera
okay okay and we'll get started
dude yeah do should i work out two or
yeah yeah you can work out after just
hold the camera
there's also another thing that's been
making it difficult for me the last 10
weeks and
and that's that i've been doing a lot of
snacking outside of the
the healthy food i'm going to throw it
out because i i need to have a perfect
week and get my diet
on uh on track snacks gotta go r.i.p
to the chippies and dippies so basically
this is just a joke week
i'm not getting in a good workout and my
clothes are not folded
this is not a good fold a note it's all
you out there it can be dangerous trying
to multitask
by lifting or trying to do too much at
once listen to a podcast or some great
jams a playlist while you run but don't
try to do other activities
so i'm at the park today and i'm gonna
get my workout
in front of people but i'm gonna try and
be as discreet as possible because i
gotta say this is very outside my
comfort zone
yeah i had to do squats during the
meeting today on monday
we got just played up but um now okay
eric's doing squats
are you doing slots although the footage
is gonna get used for something
yeah it will no this is for my own
personal archive
feeling a little more confident i
decided to come back they actually have
an outdoor
gym here there's a dog running towards
me
so i'm gonna fight a dog in the park no
there's an outdoor gym so i'm gonna try
and work out in front of some real
muscle heads here
some real ripped dudes and ladies
hopefully ladies to be honest
i still want those gladiator points so
i'm making sure to hit
the new phase three version of the
exercise i did the same tuesday and
monday
proud of myself for doing both
challenges i'm surprised at how well i'm
handling it so there's no
one here at the gym unfortunately
there's a group of
dog moms and dads behind me that sick
their dog on me so i'm gonna make them
watch me work out now as retaliation
darla i'm sorry i couldn't pick you up
from doggy daycare
but i had to do my mountain climbers
today can you lick the screen
so i know that you love me
darla she can see me
hello how are you good thanks for
agreeing to work down with me today
there you are my boys wait no apocalypse
style
sup [ __ ] wow that's not
i thought apocalypse style was just when
they throw the in-n-out burger at you
oh yeah
no jokes you little i want to know how
it was
facing your worst fears what i didn't
wet my bed and then get attacked by a
bear so i don't know what you're talking
about
fitness fears please oh it was hard
it was hard i was too distracted i'm so
bad at multitasking i feel like i
both had to re-watch what i wanted to
rewatch or have the new work calls that
i was having
and do more work out i uh you know felt
silly at times but
i realized like all of my fears it was
unnecessary i can't be stopped i am a
sexual physical force that deserves to
be seen
in the athletic state yeah i'll say when
you're
out there in the world and you see
someone exercising all you think to
yourself is
good for them and then you move on with
your life the only time you ever think
that person looks dumb
is when they don't want to admit they're
running so then they
start pretending they were walking the
whole time that never works
just run i will say i'm glad we did this
towards the end
of the challenge because i have gotten
much better at the exercises
if we were doing phase one programs i
would have been uh slightly more
embarrassed
tommy i'm going to make you redo them
where you do look bad doing them i want
you to have no fears doing them
and eric i do get that it's very hard to
multitask
but the key is actually to not try to
split your focus
but rather just have two things going on
while you're doing that i've done that a
ton of times that's one of my favorite
moves
for instance i watched all of jericho
wow it's just great to be able to catch
up on all those
references an essential one welcome back
to new rockstars i'm eric boss and today
we're going to find
all the easter eggs in jericho season
two
i'm jeric but you know
if you want eric boss's laser sight
breakdown skills applied
i have to be in a sensory deprivation
tank a blues sensory deprivation tank
yeah yeah i'm floating right now in
water
oh also side note great job to both of
you
actually in stepping up your workouts up
to that
phase three version as a reminder for
our gladiator competition here
i kept track of how often you completed
the full
phase three intensity of the week and
going blow by blow
eric you delivered four blows to tommy
on monday tuesday wednesday and thursday
[Applause]
tommy you blew eric twice once on
tuesday and again on wednesday to blow
guys
thank you tommy and eric i am genuinely
proud of you
despite all of this filthy humor in this
segment
i'm proud of you for getting four of
those now you have
but anyway guys the competition is only
beginning
let's talk about the steaks which could
be steak
doordash is providing eric or tommy with
a cheat meal each week
and they're providing you all with 25
off your order and zero delivery
fees as long as it's your first order
for 15 or more and that's it
you just download the doordash app and
use our code nerdfitness
previously eric and tommy both used our
code to both
order editor john multiple meals how was
your ordering experience guys uh great
it was super easy i was able to apply
that nerd fitness code to get our 25
percent off into a delivery fees
and uh make uh john feel a little bit
better i was able to get john a pretzel
a bun style cheeseburger he couldn't
stop raving about in fact i wish he
would he was calling me at all hours
telling me how that uh that bun made him
go
a reminder that's 25 off up to a 10
value and zero delivery fees on your
first order when you download the
doordash app on the app store and enter
code
nerdfitness it's the code but also it's
what we're trying to do with this show
just achieve some nerd fitness and knock
25
off your first order and maybe 25 off
these guys body fat percentages subject
to change terms apply
both to the doordash offer and to the
body fat situation
eric tommy tomorrow you both are going
to embark
on your most intense challenge yet whoa
what's on the line
what do you want that cheat meal to be
well if we're going intense
i want the classic uh hug from home
of a chipotle burrito bowl i haven't
requested it yet i've been waiting for
the right week
this is my week you know if this is
going to be intense i got to go back to
an ultimate comfort food for me and that
is delicious pasta
and i'm talking the real deal none of
these rice noodles
no whole grain noodles i'm talking
noodles made of just nothing but
stick to your body fattening sugar
starches
those are kind of honestly disgusting
sounding the way you describe them but
i will get them for you if you win great
but now
it's time to work out let's get limber
limber liver limber limber
well i'm you know i'm floating in water
so i can't really do that much
today's challenge is inspired by black
panther in that movie t'challa has to
battle for honor and to inherit the
mantle of the black panther
so we're gonna have a little bit of a
battle of honor between the two of you
oh nothing gonna be honorable about that
no now each of you is gonna be adorned
with your own black panther suit which
is fitted with some specialty armor
that contains your life force oh okay
your goal is going to be to destroy your
opponent's life force
while protecting your own my life force
is levat blue just so you know
a regional beer joke once one of you has
successfully destroyed all of your
opponent's life force
you'll be crowned the winner of the
challenge okay down voss
oh i think not
it didn't have to be this way eric but
that's the way it is tom
let the challenge begin
ah your greatest fear was looking stupid
but look at you now
[Music]
this space is my package it is beautiful
that's not vibranium it doesn't come
back
winner
now i'm thanos is that the movie we're
doing
we'll go down wait let's go f2 uh
damn look at you oh my god
god all right well i guess it's decided
eric
you clearly have what it takes to be the
king of wakanda wait that's what this is
african nation no i'm not comfortable
with that title okay
i'm not worthy of that that's not what
this was supposed to i'm just the king
of the hot tub your highness
you guys tricked me into being racist i
don't agree with this no
no i'm not gonna let anyone pound me
don't worry
you're actually not the winner of the
entire week or you could be
it all depends on how you did throughout
the week and some math that i'm gonna do
and then we'll find out which of you is
actually gonna get that sweet sweet door
dash cheat meal
happy sunday my king
let's move away from monarchy uh i'll
happily the king is making great
decisions
no now rightful king of wakanda
you may be the head of a state in
africa representing the wakandan people
very well and appropriately
a different appropriate appropriation
maybe but
there is a chance you might still not be
getting that sweet sweet door that's
cheat meal
i don't know if anyone saw that
challenge i would have a hard time
not thinking eric won he absolutely
destroyed me remember
that a lot more goes into it a little
bit more goes into yours tommy but i'll
actually tell the
audience about that instead of you by
the way your your george
drivers are well they probably left by
now but they were at your door
please go grab your unaccompanied meals
i'll tell the audience what's what
this week eric and tommy actually both
did a very
solid job with their phase 3 workouts if
you're following along with the epic
hero fitness videos you can see that the
phase 3 versions
are all about pushing yourself harder
and sometimes for a bit longer
make sure to download the infographic
linked in the description of those
workout videos to get the full workout
plan by the way
and you might be thinking that eric
destroyed the challenge which he did
and the week which he also did but i
actually gave
tommy extra points this week for having
his
first perfect meal week but
do you think that was enough to win the
week well let's see
well the disappointments keep coming
philip first thing i was greeted with
was a bag that said veggie grill which
was insulting enough
but uh upon closer examination it's uh
zucchini noodles
tommy we should get your mouth on one
end of one of those noodles
my butt on the end of the other yeah
hell yeah
oh god i heard please say something
oh ayah i got my chipotle
my dream meal but uh oh god this smells
so good um here's the deal though it is
date night for me and kelly and our
favorite date night meal is chipotle so
i'm gonna hold on to this and eat it
later
uh and kelly's gonna get some chipotle
as well how does chipotle go with date
night
any meal is a fancy new chipotle it's
like the champagne of mexican takeout
it's only available in the chipotle
region of uh your ass
all right fellas that's it for this week
of fitness origins but for those of you
watching at home
now is a great time to go subscribe to
epic hero fitness and plan your upcoming
workout week there are five days of
workouts there pick a day to start and
just
jump in both eric and tommy did it
they're still doing it and so can you
hear some people that have already
jumped in with us you guys i'm proud of
the work you've been doing and
tommy you seriously you have your
snacking under control
and the people in the audience are
jumping in i actually feel like
we're getting somewhere with this whole
fit nerd thing
great work guys i just hope it's enough
well that was ominous
all right bye-bye
fine i'll do it myself
you